thomas we're seeing a significant drop
in the number of cases but deaths
continuing to rise
both deaths and hospitalizations are up
on
yesterday uh yes so the the deaths now
uh 1162 uh in the last
24 hours that's the highest uh the
second highest in the
uh the uk's epidemic you have to go all
the way back to the 21st of april
uh for the day when the only day uh that
they were higher that was
1224 back then but significantly the
pressure on hospitals continues to rise
as well so another 300 people
have been admitted to hospital um in the
last
24 hours so that takes it up to 30
370 patients being treated
uh for covid19 now and and it just shows
uh that hospitals are likely to
continue to suffer this rapid rise in
the number of patients that
they're seeing although the cases have
come down uh on yesterday
yesterday by about ten thousand so today
uh in the last 24 hours 52
600 uh were diagnosed with covid19
you have to bear in mind that there are
daily fluctuations because of the time
of year all the bank holidays as a lag
in in patient uh being reported and and
so on so
it's likely that uh there will be a
continued rise in in hospital admissions
and deaths for for another couple of
weeks before the effect the lockdown is
being failed